three weeks from thursday
there will be a placing of the
jacksonville jaguars on the clock
in las vegas nevada for the first ever
las vegas
centric draft las vegas hosted draft the
nfl draft i'll be there for nfl network
and one of the best in the business
looking at tape looking at film and
evaluating from nfl film senior producer
greg cosell here back on the rich eisen
show how you doing greg rich how are you
i am great i can't wait i'm very excited
look and i know that people are like
well quarterbacks aren't atop the draft
so on and so forth and uh but uh there
are some big time players who's the best
player in the draft that you see uh you
think
what do you got for me i'm not good at
that stuff ridge um i think you could
make a case for uh in this particular
draft
i think ahmad gardner probably fits into
that conversation
or i guess we should say sauce gardener
yes sir
um
yeah uh i mean i i particularly like
evan neal as as the best left tackle
prospect maybe he fits into that
category
um
you know i think aiden hutchinson will
be a really good player i don't know if
he's a special player um
so yeah that's it's that's a hard
question i don't know i don't do a board
so i don't think of it in those terms no
i understood i i get you um i guess then
i guess safest and things of that nature
are the words that that are used but
it's all an evaluation when it's said
and done what is your evaluation of
kavon thibodeaux
um i think thibodeau's a good prospect i
don't think he's special the thing that
would
would concern might be too strong a word
but when i think of pass rushers
normally i think that one trait i would
like to see
really outstanding pass pressures have
is the ability to
as we say clear the ark and then flatten
and close to the quarterback he's a
little tight-hipped and he struggles at
times to kind of flatten once he once
the attacks uh the outside edge of
offensive tackles
so he inv in many ways rich he reminded
me of a 20 pounds lighter to deviant
clowney
and obviously clowney came out as the
consensus number one pick and clowney
will now be likely with his fifth team
by the age of 28 and the reason that's
the case is because he's not a premium
edge pass rusher because premium edge
pass rushers are not with their 15 by
the time they're the age of 28 because
it's such an important position in the
nfl so thibodeau reminded me a little
bit of clowney with his traits and his
skill set and just that that ability to
bend and be flexible when you attack the
high side of offensive tackles he just
did not flatten the way you'd like
someone to when you think of the von
millers of the world those guys who are
truly special age rushers so when you
you look at the jaguars and all the
moves that they've made in free agency
um and all the moves that they've made
since the uh beginning of the the
non-playing season as we call it in the
nfl
you you can basically say they're going
to go with an edge rusher they're going
to go with a pass rusher first overall
and there's trayvon walker in the mix as
well who would you
counsel based on your evaluation
jacksonville to choose at that spot what
do you think
wow i mean you know
i
my opinion on that based on film study
and that's all i do so i don't get to
meet these players i know i'm sure aiden
hutchinson is a terrific kid
and i think he'll be a good pro
the player and i doubt he will be the
number one pick in the draft but the
player who i think of this particular
group of pass rushers that in two three
four years we could be talking about as
the best of the group is jermaine
johnson from florida state
now i doubt he'll be the number one pick
in the draft but i think that his
combination of traits and his skill set
are such that i could easily see him
being the best pass rusher of the group
uh when as time goes by now hutchinson
is a very complete player
uh i think he's a really good prospect
he's he's not a bendy flexible player
he uses his hands really well he's got
short area explosiveness um he obviously
plays with tremendous competitiveness
all the time um but
i i think jermaine johnson as we go
further down the road will be
arguably the best pass rusher of this
group well up the turnpike from where
you uh you work sir i mean i know you
don't traffic in the world of mock
drafts but so many mock drafts have
jeremy and johnson winding up with the
giants and giants fans are freaking out
right now over that possibility they're
freaking out in a good way or a bad well
i hope it's a good way because the kid
lit it up at the combine and i've heard
nothing but great things about him what
do you see on on film that makes you say
what you just said correct well
first of all i i love the way he's built
he's kind of long he's lean he's sinewy
he really looks athletic and he plays
that way um
i think that he plays with power that
sometimes belies his his wiry frame but
there's a power element to his game both
as a run defender and pass rusher he's
naturally quick there's just a quickness
to his movement i thought he used his
hands effectively um
i wouldn't say he's he's a
natural bender off the edge in a strict
sense but he can bend
and i think that he's only scratching
the surface of his ability to rush the
quarterback so i i think that he's a guy
you can line up on the edge i think you
can move him around your front using
what we call a joker where he stands up
and moves around and you look for match
ups with him
and he's got excellent closing burst and
speed so i really liked his tape a lot
he had some really dominant snaps in the
run game versus north carolina state
left tackle ikali ike iguanu which is um
pretty surprising given iguana was just
a man amongst boys when it comes to the
run game great greg cosell here on the
rich eisen show he's used the word match
up a few times and why not he's the ep
and analyst on nfl matchup with matt
bowen and sal pal senior producer of nfl
films for 42 years and counting right
here on the rich eisen show your
evaluation of the quarterback class is
what greg cosell
i would probably put kenny pickett at
the top of that list um i think that
he's just a very efficient ball
distributor uh i think that he has
better mobility than people give him
credit for you know to me
it's if you reduce the quarterback
position and there's so many variables
rich as you know and we could have this
conversation for three hours um but
ultimately it's it's to make the right
kind of throw to the right receiver at
the right time and i think that kenny
pickett does that extremely well i think
he's well schooled in the kinds of past
game concepts that
he needs to know to be an nfl
quarterback because mark whipple was his
offensive coordinator and mark whipple
has nfl experience so you can see on
tape that he's familiar with those
concepts and combinations um so to me
he's the best i hear i hear a lot about
he doesn't have a special trait um i
understand what people mean by that but
no one is suggesting he's josh allen you
know the point is is can he be an
efficient quarterback who can execute
your offense snap after snap after snap
and make the occasional improvisational
play with his legs he can be that guy
and i think he's prepared to play
essentially right now
what about uh the rest of the group walk
me through who else said
i think it'll be in the eye of the
beholder you know it's funny if you talk
to coaches
and ask them to give you a list of
quarterback traits that they view as
important
what in some ways would be
non-negotiables obviously the main trade
would be ball location and ball
placement because you theoretically
could do everything right as a
quarterback rich but if you can't throw
the ball where you want to then you
essentially have nothing and i think
quarterback traits start with so many
things that people don't talk about it
starts with fundamentals mechanics
repetitive mechanics you think of
someone like tom brady who who did not
make plays outside the structure of the
offense but his repetitive mechanics
every single snap it was exactly the
same
you know and and the reason i mention
that is because to me
throwing the ball hard and running fast
are not quarterback traits that are
necessarily at the top of anybody's list
so i know that people talk about malik
willis that way his tape in 2021 was not
very good and he ran an offense which of
course is not his fault he's just the
quarterback running the offense he's
given but he ran an offense that was
very remedial and simplistic relative to
what he's going to have to do in the nfl
so he can throw it hard and he can run
fast and we'll see where his career goes
and who drafts him he's he's going to
need to be
in a really well coached system that
defines things for him really cleanly
certainly early in his career um
the other quarterbacks in this draft i
think all have issues that
some can be coached some
can't be coached i think sam howell has
very good traits um he will freely admit
he did not have a good year in 2021 he
will freely admit that he tried to do
too much and therefore he left the
pocket way too soon he he did not want
to be in the pocket he wanted to get out
of the pocket he didn't feel comfortable
being there so now we'll see if that
translates or if he calms down and can
run an offense because he he's a good
thrower of the football uh he's got a
good deep arm he is mobile um
matt corral matt corral ran an offense
again that it was an rpo quick game
offense he can snap the ball off well
particularly in the short intermediate
game he's got that whip-like delivery
very compact ball comes out
but that lane kiffin offense was quick
game rpo and take some deep shots so and
he ran a lot and he's not going to be
doing that in the nfl
desmond ritter to me is almost the most
fascinating of these guys because he ran
a lot of pro-style concepts he has some
issues as well he's way too deliberate
in his drop and at times with his
delivery it can be a little elongated he
tends at times to drop his arm angle a
little bit low which causes ball
placement issues and he missed far too
many layups but i think in the right
kind of offense where the run game is a
featured foundation and there's play
action
i think he can be very effective and i
think that he made some some what we
would call nfl throws within the context
of the cincinnati offense
we've got greg cosell a few minutes left
with the nfl film senior producer here
on the rich eisen show uh one of the
keenest eyes evaluating uh that we can
talk to so um last couple years justin
jefferson and jamar chase remarkable
rookie seasons at the receiver position
um
the kid based on what you've seen over
the all 22 that is mo
you know would have a shot to make it
three in a row um with significant
rookie seasons would be which receiver
wow that's a great question because
chase was a no-brainer jefferson was not
a no-brainer by the way and he's
obviously been phenomenal but he was not
a no-brainer
i'm really intrigued with garrett wilson
he kind of reminds me a little bit of
stefan diggs in the way in which he
plays and i think that's obviously a
pretty good comparison
um
i'm trying to think of all the other
receivers in this draft right now i've
seen the receiver's probably the
position i've watched the most players
so there's so many guys yeah they really
are they were they were they lit up they
lit up uh lucas oil the combine i mean
well you know it's funny just to respond
to that point i think you're going to
see now going forward because of sports
science and advanced technology and
training we're going to see just
unbelievable performances i mean being
there on the saturday night watching the
d-line and linebackers sitting in the
dome i mean these guys the athleticism
is off the charts and it's only going to
continue to get better and better
because of the nature of training um but
as far as receivers
treylon burks fascinates me because he's
a big man who moves well regardless of
his 40 time he plays much faster he's
got really big hands he catches
everything i think you can move him
around quite a bit i think there's a
little bit of debo samuel to him in the
fact that you can line them up all over
including the backfield um of course you
know some might see that more as a
negative than a positive
because there's a debuff samuel but
there's also a leviskus chanal who some
thought could be that guy and hasn't
turned out to be that guy up to this
point um but burke's really fascinates
me before i let you go greg cosell i'm
going to ask you a sports talk radio
question i'm giving that boy here we go
okay i'm gonna here we go here we go at
least i walk through the front door here
all right all right yeah okay i'm gonna
give you four
acquisitions from this the march was
insane as you know in the nfl okay i'm
gonna give you four acquisitions and
let's use your match up brain your
scheme fit brain here and you tell me
which is gonna be the most
significant
in terms of uh positive positive results
this fall okay okay i need i need the
most right i mean all four of them are
all four of them are going to be
significant but that's what the sports
talk radio can only choose one all right
which one is going to be the most
significant this fall wind up being the
most significant the acquisition of
russell wilson for nathaniel hackett
okay
the acquisition of um devonte adams for
derek carr
the acquisition of tyree kill fertua and
mike mcdaniel or the acquisition of matt
ryan for frank reich i'll give you those
four again
russell wilson okay okay you go i got it
okay which one you got for me which one
i'm gonna go tyree kill for this reason
because i think mike mcdaniel really
understands what tua is as most people
do when you talk to coaches at the
combine about tour they all understand
his limitations and what he has to be in
order to be effective so now you have
the rpo game and the quick game throws
to two burners in waddle and hill who
can take short passes and go the
distance because that's what their pass
game needs to be and i think that the
acquisition of hill really will impact
that significantly because now you can
have one guy on each side and that that
makes you know two is an rpo quarterback
um and he can throw the deep ball but
he's not a sit on his back foot and
drive the ball in the middle of the
field quarterback so you need the quick
game you need the rpo game and i think
hill who ran an rpo game was part of an
rpo game in kansas city he can take
those quick slants those glance routes
and he can turn them into much more see
that was an answer to a sports talk
radio question and we're both surviving
it we both lived that was great no i
mean i gave you a football answer we did
which is great so here's what it's a
here's a bonus one then which one which
oh here you go which and i know that we
don't know in the draft because you know
i'm assuming both of these teams are
going to draft a rookie receiver in the
first round which one is more of a
significant departure that will affect
the way that they operate hill
now no longer being there for my homes
or atoms for rogers which one adam's for
rogers
because that was basically their pass
game to a large large extent i was
almost close to seeing adams to your
first question because i think devante
adams is the best wide receiver in the
game right and and so i was very close
to that but i just thought that with the
speed and the way
the way they need to sort of orchestrate
their pass game that hill is really a
big factor for miami but adams to me has
been over the last couple years the the
most complete
wide receiver you could say hill's
clearly more dynamic and more explosive
that's without question but i think
adams is the most complete wide receiver
over the last couple of years yeah i
know i i you right green bay is going to
have to get a a receiver they're going
to have to draft a receiver somewhere
along the line well first round right i
mean we can't you would think wouldn't
you well you do have to line up with
whiteouts in this league
i mean rogers will need to get started
with the kid he might actually bring the
card up in vegas and then just take him
and go somewhere and start they're gonna
go back to the packer sweep with a seal
here and a seal there that's right vince
well done well done sir thank you so
much greg cosell say hi to everybody uh
in at films for me we'll chat again soon
great appreciate it appreciate it thank
you very much greg cosell right there on
the rich eisen shell i love talking him
makes me smarter
at greg cosell on twitter
i follow him you should as well hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here